vous avez des soucis côté coeur ça ne va
pas fort techniquement mais pas au point
c'est bien excusez moi et puis j'ai fait
des reds et des zooms l'info ce mot ce
gabarit
c'est comme avec les familles il n'est
pas jaloux ils ne s'occupent pas de moi
là je veux faire tout ce que je veux au
moment où je veux faire je vous retrouve
un dec à poigne qui s'occupera mois que
dois-je faire ensemble madame vous
voulez un homme à poigne de préférence
que sa poigne s'abattre sur vous vous me
faites penser un peu aux enfants qui
parce que leur mère leur accorde pas
assez d'attention font beaucoup de
bêtises pour recevoir une fessée et vous
décidément vous voulez recevoir une
fessée devriez lire l'avis d'un monsieur
qui s'appelait sacher masoch qui a donné
son nom au masochisme
pendant toute sa vie il avait demandé à
sa femme de combler un de ses désirs il
était attaché et tout en étant attaché
il devait voir cette femme qu'il aime
est possédée par un tsigane
quelle douleur sa femme après bien des
atermoiements lui a donné cette
satisfaction instantanément il l'a
quitté alors méfiez vous il y a des
jalons qui ne sont pas amoureux il y à
des bretons qui ne sont pas très gentils
et si vous prenez un homme apprennent
dans la poignée trop solide pour risquer
de faire abîmé la figure et ce serait
dommage madame parce qu'elle échappement
france est un problème pour les autres
ont très bien
des relations sexuelles tout à fait
normal mais malheureusement est
maintenant six mois que je sors avec la
même fille et je m'aperçois que après
avoir fait l'amour elle manque et elle
mange elles mangent elles mangent de
plus en plus alors déjà il ya des
problèmes des fils de l'infini et fils
dans la cuisine et elle revient tout un
tas de de gâteaux etc
déjà vous parce que les miettes
et tout ça mais en plus elle a fini par
grossir grossir trick embonpoint et
plusieurs kilos alors la france ma
question est que dois-je faire pour que
quelque chose va faire du bois vous
voulez qu'elle perde du point où vous
voulez qu'elle cesse d'aller à la
cuisine évidemment l'un a même l'autre
débouté moi je crois que si vous voulez
l'a poussé à faire un régime
vous devriez après avoir eu avec elles
les rapports satisfaisants que vous
décrivez la regarder avant qu'elle se
rhabille d'un oeil critique en lui
disant dit dans tu ne crois pas que tu
devrais maigrir un peu j'ai l'impression
que c'est le moment psychologique qui
n'empêchera balaie la cuisine
deuxième solution avant ces rapports
satisfaisants
vous pourriez l'emmener manger un
couscous une bonne potée un plat
consistant elles seront en train de
digérer et elle aura peut-être moins
envie d'aller la cuisine troisièmement
vous pouvez vider complètement le
restaurateur
enfin quatrièmement éviter tout ce qui a
des miettes dans la maison ni pain ni
gattoni biscuits bonne chance un enfant
c'est autant de temps sur l'amour parce
que parce que j'ai des relations
qui étaient les jeunes femmes maintenant
et j'ai l'impression que j'en donne pas
ce qu'ils attendent et bon j'aimerais
bien savoir combien de temps ça doit
durer
monsieur permettez moi de vous parler
comme je parlerai parce que vous êtes
très jeune
ainsi ce qui nous posera la même
question et je lui dirais mon chéri les
rapports amoureux n'ont rien à voir avec
une compétition sportive
il ne s'agit pas de battre des records
de lenteur comme d'autres bacs des
records de vitesse
on a appris que dans la vie quand on
ouvrait une porte devant une femme on
les disait après vous ai bien l'amour
c'est mieux c'est un peu comme ça
considère que faire l'amour avec une
femme c'est lui proposer une promenade
alors le fonds spa commence à explorer
la géographie regarde les paysages
cherche ses secrets et puis tu connais
la fable de la fontaine le lièvre et la
tortue le lièvre courait aussi vite que
toi il était jeune et vigoureux bien sûr
mais il est quand même arrivé après la
tortue pourquoi parce qu'il s'est arrêté
de temps en temps pour parler bien sûr
on peut faire autre chose que parler
alors ce qu'on peut faire d'autre tu
sais c'est raconter dans beaucoup de
bons livres est beaucoup dans de mauvais
film mais le mieux tu vois tu le
trouveras dans ton coeur parce que
beaucoup de jeunes mamans inexpérimentée
ont réinventé tous les secrets des vieux
dont je vends fatigué et puis si tu n'y
arrives pas et bien recommence plus dur
commencera plus tu as des chances
contenir assez mérette accompagne si
vous voulez que je vous réponde envoyez
moi vos questions à antenne 2 22 avenue
montaigne 75008 paris ou bien utiliser
le minitel en faisant le 36 15 91 77
étape est d'abord à 2